most critics writing about Avengers
infinity war praised the movie for
depicting an oppressive defeat a unique
characteristic in the superhero genre
Marvel took incredible risks offering
little hope beyond the promise of a
resolving chapter so I want to ask a
question would the ending have been so
successful had the movie come out before
the 2016 election I don't think the
question is very fair because I'm pretty
sure people would love the movie
regardless cliffhangers aren't anything
new after all however asking the
question can lead to an interesting
reading of both infinity war and endgame
as Winter Soldier and Civil War eerily
reflected the political climates in
which they were made I want to see how
these later Marvel entries reflect their
times and how they may even predict or
act as a warning for the times to come
Thanos is pretty easy to see his Trump
however the right certainly has their
takes on him all social justice warriors
lefties blizzards or whatever you want
to call them have the same what great to
live in the world where humanity lives
in perfect harmony with the environment
all things are equal and perfectly
balanced as all things should be sound
familiar
infinity war is really about the war
against dangerous leftist ideologies
it's about one more Mike Trump Thanos is
a laughable strange colored monster
brooding on the edge of a long story
seen by most as another caricature to be
easily defeated there's not going to be
a President Donald Trump
that's not gonna happen both are
charismatic and persuasive thrust first
I mean why else Cronus Thanos constantly
defies our expectations and breaks rules
set by the larger narrative constantly
he is underestimated by his enemies I
continue to believe mr. Trump will not
be President
Thanos comes to power through a gradual
process that only seems unstoppable
after it can no longer be stopped and
most significantly Thanos is wrong
renegade cut made a fantastic essay
about the specific subject so I suggest
you check it out if you still need to be
convinced I guess what most connects the
2016 election to the events of infinity
war is this sense of defeat particularly
the defeat of those still confident in
winning the Trump fan o's comparison is
pretty obvious so I want to focus more
on the Avengers themselves who have
stood as a type of neoliberal safeguard
throughout the 2010s much has been said
about the superhero genre as a sort of
fantasy of the benevolent dictator a
desire to jettison democracy for a faith
in a supposedly superior human if
anything separates the Avengers from
this reading it's that the Avengers act
as an organized coalition most of the
time and don't completely operate
outside of the government the Obama
years brought a sense of normalcy to
many liberals but a shake up of the
political system he was not like the
Avengers Obama's administration put
band-aids on problems without fully
solving them he won't protect the world
[Music]
or set out to fix what had been broken
in their own efforts to remedy the issue
Obamacare was a far cry from reforming
the health care system hawk-like
international policies were carried over
from the Bush era civilians will kill
that shouldn't have been economic
inequality increased while climate
change was exacerbated thanks Obama but
at least Obama was there a figure of
decency and strength a steady head of
state the guardian of the best
neoliberal values our world had to offer
problems plagued the world but at least
the Avengers were there to usually
return things back to the way they were
the MCU eerily reflected isolated
political situations in the 2010s Winter
Soldier coming out soon after the
Snowden scandal and civil war coming out
before one of the most divisive
elections in American history
while the Avengers are there to stop
threats with strength and ingenuity the
true danger was always lurking just
beneath the surface Tony could feel it
that up there that's that's it again and
yet the Avengers could only solve the
immediate issues not the underlying
problems
The Avengers proved unsuccessful in
dealing with the fundamental issues that
plagued their society when an outsider
arrives who offers a solution to the
problems however wrong he may be he
proves unstoppable
Thanos of course wasn't elected to
anything and really doesn't convince
anybody throughout the course of the
films but the problems he is addressing
are those that matter and are generally
relegated outside of the MCU you know
poverty starvation symptoms of
capitalism like Trump Thanos identified
the problems and like Trump the
solutions were dead wrong Trump solution
was to demonize immigrants stoic racial
resentment easy when so many are angry
they enosis solution was to eliminate
half of all life in the universe Thanos
is a fascist while the Avengers are sort
of like a benevolent oligarchy if we see
Tony as the leader the group is sort of
like an Elon Musk
daddy fantasy checkout philosophy - by
the way let's just say the Avengers
aren't socialists they could never be
based on the company that creates them
in our world they'd be the type to see
capitalism not as a problem in itself
war capitalists was it surprising that a
force of heroes ignoring the underlying
issues of society were defeated by a
villain who wants to fix those ills
Thanos like the Avengers understands
capitalism as a truth of the world
America will never be a socialist
country like Trump his diagnosis
misunderstands the heart of the problem
which is the nature of capitalism not
that there are too many mouths to feed
his illogical solution is one that would
make sense to those that don't
understand capitalism what happened in
2016 was the absolute worst case
scenario to many people the defeat left
a vacancy and still leaves a vacancy in
the hearts of many whose way of living
is threatened every day Trump is in the
White House as 2020 approaches it feels
a bit like the build-up to the release
of Avengers endgame there's a ton of
anticipation and a ton of guessing Trump
like Thanos has to be defeated and will
it's inevitable everyone thinks so right
but how this is what we were asking
before we sat down in theaters after a
year of waiting to watch end game we
knew Thea nose would get defeated
but how end game is amazing filmmaking I
cheered like everyone else did at the
big moments I laughed I cried it was
everything I wanted it to be but it's a
movie that sours the longer I think
about it not because I'm obsessed with
its inconsistent time-travel logic or
anything but because it's political
subtext is mildly upsetting if the snap
was the 2016 election endgame is 2020
Thanos won and we have to undo it and if
the Avengers stand as the new liberal
old guard and democratic establishment
then their solution is a problem because
their solution is well
literal [ __ ] time-travel I can't
think of a more perfect metaphor for
what the old guard Democrats want in
2020 than literal time travel Wow Lord
when good candidates are actually
proposing ideas to rid the country of
the problems that created Trump the
Democratic establishment continues to
push their weakened beleaguered base
toward candidates whose only vision for
America is to return to a state of
normalcy return to the essence of who we
are
we got Trump because the state of
normalcy was inadequate for everybody we
got Trump because the neoliberal
approach to capitalism had been failing
the world for decades the Avengers world
is different from our own of course they
lost 50% of the population yet somehow
watching them succeed in returning the
world to normal while destroying Thanos
feels wrong maybe I feel jaded maybe
it's because we haven't defeated our own
Thanos yet maybe it's because I know
that trying to turn the clock back to
the Obama years is the wrong solution
it's a fantasy
it's a fantasy that could work only for
the Avengers what do you think the
single biggest difference would be
between an Obama White House and a Biden
White House in terms of hopefully acting
and dealing with integrity and dealing
with look look when so many actually
believe this fantasy in our real world
seeing it depicted so expertly on screen
just bothers man I hope that in 2020 we
defeat our own vanos and without
time-travel because let's face it we
could never go back to the Obama years
time-travel literal and metaphorical is
just impossible while the Avengers
brought back the population and defeated
Thanos their world and all of the MCU is
going to be different too and I hope it
reflects that in the upcoming films we
can't pretend that this fantasy of
returning to normal will save us that
anything except a new direction and a
new approach to capitalism will defeat
our Thanos endgame was made by one of
the largest companies in the world the
stories they tell matter the messages
they carry overt or not matter an
endgame reflects a very dangerous
fantasy which is maybe why it's so
satisfying it's satisfying to see the
old
heroes we love get a second shot to
defeat the big bad man I said if we were
in high school I'd take you behind the
gym and beat the hell out of them but in
the real world it doesn't work like that
and I only hope that before 2020
Democrats stop fantasizing and wake up
[Music]
how you gonna get those voters well I
think just by making the case that that
we have to restore dignity to work
what's the last time we went out and
thanked the guy who kept the sewer from
overflowing and going into your basement
you say Joey my jobs about a lot more
than the paycheck it's about your
dignity